You ever had a first love?
Yeah, who hasn't, right?
My first love was football.
I was raised five years in Iowa,
-and...
-CROWD MEMBERS: Yeah!
You from Iowa?
Hey, man, let me ask you
somethin'.
What do you think
about this electricity?
(LAUGHTER)
-(RIMSHOT)
-(CACKLES)
That's just funny.
(CACKLES)
Ah, god, quit it, Terry.
And I used to stand in front
of the Sears and Roebuck window
on Main Street in Clinton, Iowa.
CROWD MEMBER: I'm from there!
You stood there? You too?
What is this?
(LAUGHTER)
Don't talk unless I ask you to.
I'm being paid up here.
Don't forget.
You're not getting paid.
No, you paid.
Matter of fact, you can talk.
I don't care.
But you stood there
at the Sears window.
And I looked in and they had
all the Hawkeye stuff.
And I love-- and get this,
it was like one of those,
what do you call it?
Premonition?
-Is that what you call it?
-CROWD MEMBER 2: Premonition.
Yeah, that. Who said that?
Where'd you graduate?
You got a college degree?
You gotta. That's a big word.
Premonition, yeah, that's good.
Can you spell it?
(LAUGHTER)
So I'm prem-- I'm pre--
I'm premonitioning.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
And I'm seeing that
black and gold helmet
and all that uniform
and I see that football there.
I'm like, "God, if Santa Claus
will bring me a football,
I'll be the happiest guy
in the world."
And I got it.
And I got my first football,
and it was like...
I smelled it,
put my hands on it.
It was just love at first touch.